they need to be resettled elsewhere
this is a massive country this is a
Friday clip I love you and and
I say this a lot but like this is top 10
view Insanity so the New York City is
being overrun by illegals right now
we've shown you the clip of Mayor Eric
Adams basically basically being like you
better get the F out of here there's
nothing I can do man you're screwed it's
coming everywhere Upper East Side
downtown below Houston doesn't matter
you're F sorry anyway the ladies of the
view and the view is shot in New York
City they're finally realizing that if
you let thousands hundreds of thousands
of people into your city it causes
problems but now
because a liberal a conservative is just
a liberal mug by reality now look at
their response now that it is quite
literally at their doorstep this is
spectacular
but frankly you know I think we need to
find and we've dealt with this before I
I lived in uh in Miami I was a migrant
an immigrant in Miami in the 80s you all
remember when we had the Marielle Boat
Lift yeah 125 000 Cubans yeah came in a
matter of six months it puts tremendous
stress on on on a city on a community on
the social services they need to be
resettled elsewhere
massive country and it's only going to
get worse with global warming and
climate change because people can't live
in certain parts of this world
I can't even write fast enough to do
this segment properly first off they
need to be resettled elsewhere do you
guys know the phrase NIMBY not in my
backyard it's the hypocrisy of these
Elite rich women they don't give a
when this is happening in the Border
towns of Texas how many times on The
View have they ever covered a Border
Town in Texas being overrun by illegal
immigrants zero the only time they've
ever covered any of this is when they
show up in Martha's Vineyard right when
DeSantis sends them up to Martha's
Vineyard 20 people where they could have
been on Obama's uh 30-acre estate each
taken an acre they would have been okay
you could even put 30 people on an acre
on one acre and they would have been
okay and then they care about this stuff
so this idea first off they have to be
resettled also there's like a twang of
like Nazism in there we'll resettle
these dirty people they can't all be
here spread them out throughout the
country how about you can't come into
the country in the first place but it's
just it's so incredible it really is
just so profoundly astounding how easily
you can punch holes in their hypocrisy
and and in the nonsense that they
espouse all the time because the second
it hits them then they care then they're
into resettling and spreading people out
again okay you want to spread people out
how about outside of the United States
that might be okay and then finally
joyless Behar with her yes it's climate
change guys it's just going to keep
happening because of climate change but
we can't have everybody coming to the
Upper West Side because I want to go to
zabars and I can't have homeless people
sitting outside just absolutely insane